ahora vamos a conectar el lado negativo
de nuestra batería a nuestros
interruptores así que tomamos un cable
blanco pelado este cable tiene cerca de
tres cuartos de pulgada sin aislante y
vamos a doblarlo y meterlo en la
terminal central de uno de nuestros
interruptores de un polo y dos
posiciones escogimos el cable blanco
porque sobresale del soporte negro de
las baterías dobles y esto hace que sea
más fácil de ver realmente puedes
utilizar cualquier color que desees
mientras el cable sea de cobre aluminio
o algo conductivo bien estamos pensando
este cable contra esta terminal que
sobresale del interruptor de un polo y
dos posiciones y el cable va a pegarse
directamente y esto hará que sea más
fácil de conectar ahora cortaremos el
sobrante del cable y en realidad lo dejé
un poco más corto de lo que
probablemente debería porque recuerda
que es bueno hacer sobresalir el cable y
lo mejor es dejar cerca de media pulgada
por delante del soporte de la batería
es doble a ahora vamos a conectar las
dos terminales de nuestros interruptores
vamos a conectar las dos terminales
centrales juntas y para hacer esto vamos
a necesitar quitar cerca de media
pulgada de aislante de los dos lados de
nuestro cable blanco restante y vamos a
insertar este cable nuevamente a través
del bloque de terminales y este cable va
al bloque central del interruptor puesto
y además pelaremos el otro extremo del
cable para que sea más fácil conectarlo
al otro extremo esto básicamente nos
facilita la manera de conectar el lado
negativo de las baterías a nuestros
interruptores y estos interruptores nos
van a permitir invertir la polaridad de
los motores provocando que el robot
retroceda es una manera sencilla de
programar la maquinaria del robot
bien solo estamos pasando nuestro cable
a través de este pequeño agujero lo
vamos a doblar y de nuevo vamos a tomar
nuestras pinzas de punta y vamos a
pensar bien este cable en su lugar
así tendremos una conexión eléctrica
bien firme y es realmente importante que
estas conexiones estén bien apretadas ya
que como no usamos soldadura la
electricidad no fluirá si estas
conexiones no están bien apretadas y el
robot no funcionará como debería este
cable es un poco más largo y lo que haré
será esperar este cable se aflojó así
que lo voy a pensar de nuevo en el otro
interruptor y el cable que acabamos de
unir está un poco largo así que en lugar
de cortar lo voy a enroscar lo ya había
pelado sí así que voy a trenzar lo
contra ese cable expuesto de igual
manera que hicimos con los leds y las
resistencias y esto nos permitirá tener
una buena conexión y extender el lado
negativo de nuestra batería a nuestros
interruptores así que aquí tenemos
nuestro cable negativo de color negro y
lo vamos a cortar y después lo vamos a
pelar de nuevo probablemente lo peleemos
cerca de bueno entre media pulgada a
tres cuartos de pulgada eso estaría
bastante bien
bueno tener un poco más de cable extra y
asegurarte de que no es demasiado corto
este es un poco difícil de pelar porque
el aislante es muy blando y puede ser
difícil de trabajar pero no hay que
jalar muy fuerte o vamos a dañar los
hilos porque recuerda este es un cable
de hilos contrario a un cable sólido así
que tomaremos estos hilos y vamos a
envolverlos alrededor de nuestros cables
trenzados y eso nos va a permitir
conectar el lado negativo de nuestra
batería a nuestros interruptores y
comenzar a armar el resto del circuito
ahora vamos a trenzar los cables es un
poco complicado porque recuerda que el
cable de hilos tiende a dispersarse así
que puede que tengamos que trabajar un
poco con ellos porque es muy importante
mantener todos los cables de hilos
contra los otros cables de centro sólido
porque si tienes un cable sobresaliendo
en algún lado puede provocar un
cortocircuito o hacer una mala conexión
así que de nuevo sólo vamos a trenzar
estos cables y para hacerlo mejor
vamos a usar nuestras pinzas de punta
y vamos a tratar de que quede lo más
estrecho posible con el fin de encerrar
esos cables de y los vamos a tomar un
pequeño pedazo de papel aluminio este de
aquí y vamos a envolverlo alrededor de
estos cables como lo hicimos con los
leds esto nos ayudará a evitar que los
cables de hilos sobresalgan en alguna
parte en la cual no deberían de
sobresalir y además nos ayudarán a
conducir la electricidad a veces es
difícil lograr que el papel aluminio se
pegue a los interruptores pero pueden
hacerlo no espera quise decir que se
pegan los cables después para mantener
todo junto y aislado vamos a tomar de
nuevo un pequeño pedazo de cinta de
aislar no se cerca de media pulgada de
largo y sólo la vamos a envolver
alrededor y además vamos a apretar lo
más fuerte que podamos para asegurarnos
que tengamos una buena conexión de nuevo
esto es sólo para tener una conexión
realmente apretada y lo que haremos
antes de terminar cualquier cosa o antes
de pegar cualquier otra cosa es probarlo
para asegurarnos de que estamos
recibiendo la energía
a correcta ahora tenemos el led
conectado el interruptor si funciona y
eso indica que el cable negativo está
funcionando así que probaremos el otro
también sí perfecto también funciona así
que tenemos toda la energía fluyendo a
través del circuito por lo tanto ahora
podemos ponerle silicón caliente a
nuestro lado negativo de la batería
asegúrate de desconectar las
resistencias antes de hacer esto así que
podemos tomar un poco de silicón
caliente aquí van de nuevo observa que
la gota que estoy agregando tiene
aproximadamente el tamaño de una moneda
de 5 pesos y así la gota tiene el tamaño
suficiente para cubrir el conector y
queremos estar seguros de que el silicón
caliente corre completamente alrededor
del cable y eso lo ayudarán a sostenerlo
en su lugar en cuanto corramos el robot
el pegamento permanezca y no se caiga
perfecto ahora estamos listos para el
siguiente paso